hey everyone and welcome to console crew
this week we're going to be talking
about the abundance
of free games that are currently on
offer so that means we'll be talking
about xbox game pass
playstations 10 free games they're
giving to everyone and then we'll be
talking about nintendo
joining me as usual i've got xbox expert
jordan remay
yo and playstation pro tomorrow hussein
i love free
i love bits if it's free then it's for
me
all right let's get into it
what's this just in even more free games
from xbox
just in who's justin over to you justin
justin no i can think of a more subtle
way of doing that because this week has
just been
completely dominated by xbox game pass
just like when you thought they didn't
have more to give
they chuck out other stuff like fps
boost they chuck out bethesda stuff they
check out improvements they check out
suspending stuff jordan it's been a huge
week um i don't even know where you want
to start with
xbox games i don't know either like
because as you said like all this free
stuff and then they are like oh and by
the way undertale is on its way and
outriders is going to come to game pass
too and it's like there's
what 20 plus games coming to game pass
for
free like over the course of the next
four or five weeks
uh it's discoverability for a lot of
those like smaller games on game pass i
think is really going to improve just
with
xbox pushing the service as hard as it
is because right now xbox doesn't have
anything like really huge in the
pipeline other than halo
infinite that we know of so just being
like oh by the way here's improvements
to pray
here's improvements to dishonor
definitive edition by the way do you
want to check out all these other
like smaller games that we also have on
game pass that maybe you haven't heard
of but you're just looking to
possibly try introducing you to a whole
genre that you've never
even maybe considered before it's
it's mind-boggling what xbox is managing
to get away with with game pass ultimate
as you know i like to make edits
incredibly more complicated for max and
here we go again and so here we are i
think that
we should this is an opportunity for us
to you know how everyone has the
uh gabe newell valve steam cell image
where he's like the pope and there's
just like sales
numbers yes everyone has that yeah it's
my desktop background
yeah everyone knows it everyone loves it
i think this is an opportunity for
console crew to lead the way by creating
a similar one around game parts for phil
spencer
so uh evan max i just added about seven
hours till edit time
well i mean that's the thumbnail for
this week's episode it's just big phil
given
giving away games but no i mean i
honestly like just looking at what's
been coming to game pass
and honestly my my twitter timeline
right now has been all of these people
just like
discovering prey and dishonored and that
fills my heart with glee because like
those like anything arcane makes is is
just wonderful and i cannot wait for
death lube
but it's like people who've been
sleeping on dishonored
and now like oh my god this game's
actually incredible and now that it runs
like
buttery smooth it's like the best gaming
experience i'm having
on game pass if if you haven't somehow
played dishonored and
you think it's up up your street like
you gotta play dishonored one and two
some of the best gaming experiences in
ever i think like the sonnet one is
amazing sonic 2 is just like a
master class in immersive sims and open
world
or open sandbox design and stealth like
i think as someone who's a
somewhat of a stealth connoisseur um
people call you yeah this is true he's
pretty good i was i was born
the nurse picked me up and looked at me
and said that's a stealth connoisseur
my mom was like oh is he out i didn't
realize
so given the amount of stuff that is on
game pass right now and like just
more and more keeps getting added ea
which is now on the pc version of game
pass ultimate 2.
uh you've got bethesda you have indie
titles you've got xbox tiles
how do you find you know
discoverability on the servers because
i'm pretty impressed by it honestly
i think it firstly i'd like you to rate
my ea impression
um all right e a
sports it's on game pass
electronic what's that contact if you
need a stand-in
i'm here for you i think discoverability
kind of changes from place to place
ea i think i come to ea with more of a
focus on what i want i don't go to
ea i guess discoverability is kind of
moot point on ea because i know there's
vast swaths of that that library that
have i have little to no interest in i'm
not looking for sports games that much
i'm not looking for driving games
because there aren't any new ones right
now
um so i know what i'm getting at the ea
games for the most part or if i go into
their service i'm usually like this is
the genre i need to go into
i think game pass is where
discoverability becomes trickier because
they have such a massive
breadth of franchises genres and
also just the amount of games on there
is overwhelming
i think microsoft they really need to do
better about curation and i would love
to see them start to
i don't know if it does this right now
but i would love to see them take a page
out on netflix's book and
um no they do that if you go through
it's like
for families i know i mean like i mean
like netflix
um uh kind of pays attention to what you
watch and what you like and then it's
like
hey have this game this is curated
basically it does not do that because i
just went on
to like double check and the first game
it recommended to me was
um like a fifa and i have never played a
fifa game on my xbox account
i think i think there's a lot of
opportunity no no service does
like custom recommendations well i think
i mean like if someone can figure out
the tick tock algorithm and make it work
for like streaming games and
and marketplaces that's going to be just
convinced microsoft to buy tick tock
big phil why we've gone back in time
steam does steam tries but it's like
there's so much garbo on steam that when
it does
it knows what you want and then it'll
give you something that's pure trash
and it's like put this this is in your
field and i'm like yeah i know it's in
my playground i know i like this but
this specific
thing is awful and you've recommended it
none of the others do that really well i
think the weakest of them is playstation
because it doesn't even feel like they
try it they have the standard like um
old school uh you know the the shop the
playstation
store which is segmented in various ways
and you can
find what you need but usually when i go
there i go to
i'm either going to the playstation
store for the plus section to search for
something
or there's a sale specific sale area
that i go into
beyond that i'm not like i'm not going
in there and being like
wow me and it's yeah i don't know wow me
what okay
wow i mean entertain me you can only get
uh if you want to be wild you have to go
to
battle net otherwise you're not getting
killed
it's funny you say that about the
playstation store because i
genuinely get my recommendations on what
to buy
through um seeing people tweet about
stuff like
i use my playstation pretty much every
day and i just don't
ever really tab over to the store and
browse it i just look at you know it's
it's actually usually the playstation
twitter account posting what is new
it's it's not within the console for me
um
and also the fact that you know you have
to consider spending money
i just don't i i'm very much more
specific
and uh blanket i guess when i go to the
playstation store i just immediately
search for what i want and buy it and
get out
whereas i just went on game pass just to
just to see what the layout was like um
it's been a couple weeks and
it updates all the time and i went in
and i immediately downloaded like
three games uh i got carto i got
dishonored again
i got uh the fifa the ea right now i got
the um
and i got uh void bastards and i was
like this is just this is just so easy
it's just all there for me
i totally agree with your point that i
wish it was more curated like
the fifa thing really threw me off
because i was no like
never played a fifa game why would i
like this um i mean
some of it comes from like deals
marketing oh yeah it will be you know
stuff yeah
please buy our footpath yes but but
there is there is like i feel like
there's
not a disservice but i feel like you're
not making the most of
showcasing developers and their games i
feel like it'll be a good idea because
it lets you grab like you know titles
that a lot of people play
things that aren't the big aaa
blockbusters and they can recommend
everybody this is cool i like this and
that would be a great opportunity to one
empower and mobilize your users
to kind of say this is a good game and
and put that in front of other people
because if i know like oh there's you
know
lucy and i play or at least jordan and i
play the same kind of games
um and you know if if he recommends it
or you recommend it and that gets pushed
to me
that will be amazing because then i know
oh like if lucy liked it and jordan
liked it then
the algorithm clearly is like hey these
your friends like these and you play the
same games together so you maybe should
try it
there's also a weird uh like cultural
discoverability though with game pass
even with the triple
a games like my roommate the other day
like
i walked into the room and he's like oh
yeah i'm just trying morrowind because
it's
on game pass and after like an hour he
just came into my room he's like
yeah this game controls like ass and i'm
like you have to remember like
xbox was leading western
rpgs being ported from like a pc only
club into like let's put these on
consoles too so like the original mass
effect
marlwind like they're not great
on xbox control scheme-wise and he got
to like discover
this aspect of rpg culture that he just
had never seen before and i wasn't going
to convince him to go back and
buy morrowind in 2021
the year of our law in 2020 popping down
to buy morrowind
quickly before we move on to
discoverability and stuff um i did want
to raise a point that like time you
mentioned that like
you want to know what your friends are
playing nintendo actually does this
pretty well
uh nintendo if you look and it says like
trending with friends
and so i can see a bunch of people
playing bowser's fury a bunch of people
are still playing animal crossing and so
i would love that aspect to go
in uh to be more uh prominent in game
pass because i think that would be a
really cool way to discover things
just based on what your friends are
doing because otherwise i mean i guess i
suppose you have to go into people's
profiles or
game clubs to see what people are really
doing it's not just like on the main
screen for you you have to purposely spy
on your friends
the game doesn't do it for you uh but
jordan to your point about your roommate
playing
morrowind and this is a big question and
i'm gonna go on record i think game pass
is one of the best things to happen to
video gaming in like the last 10 years i
think it is an incredible service
i know a spicy take people getting free
games and like
helping out developers with
discoverability it's a spicy take i know
but do you think that offering people so
much
choice with seemingly like no barrier to
entry like
people are going to be dropping off
games faster because they just have
like in one way it's a good thing
because people aren't
i guess paying all that money and then
not enjoying a game
but do you think it's going to have a
detrimental effect on people finishing
games like people don't
finish games the thing that i struggle
with is if i'm not having fun
um or if i'm not engaged when i get with
a game i very quickly
become aware of one the time i'm
spending playing it and two
the other things that could be doing
that would bring me some sort of joy
um that happens a lot today and i think
there's very there's quite a few games
where i know that i've played it and
thought
not for me and then i've been like but
i'm gonna give it a few more hours
and see where i go mass effect one being
one of them
like mass effect one first time i played
it i was like i'm not into this but then
i kind of stuck through it and
came back to it a few times and i was
like oh i see what's going on here and i
get it
and my worry is there might be some
games that have a
kind of you know a ramp up cycle to
being brilliant
but people because of the way they're
conditioned and trained
uh to have these all these games at
their fingertips and not really
you know pledge themselves to something
to really discover what it is
it could mean that certain games the
experiences are being
uh kind of abandoned before they've had
the opportunity to get good
and i wonder what impact that could have
on like
creative on the creative side and
development side when you
you know you have these things where
youtube videos for example like before
in the early days people were just chill
they'll be like hey how's it going
now it's like you've got 10 seconds to
give this person
seven reasons why they need to stay
around
and if you don't they will not only stop
watching they will unsubscribe
down vote you leave a shitty comment and
then your your the algorithm
will punch your channel into oblivion
and it's just like
what so now we have people who roll up
and you know at the start of the video
i'll be like doing backflips saying hey
everyone i'm going to tell you about
backflips and
i don't want that to happen to games you
know i i don't want to be i don't want
my games to be teaching me how to do
backflips
in 10 seconds i don't know what's going
on anymore
with backflips and video games i i i
like it
uh so we talked about game pass there uh
playstation is now kind of upping their
free game offerings
uh we've got play at home 2021 we
already had ratchet and clank 2016 but
now we've got like
a bunch of games like abzu and the
gungeon res infinite subnautica the
witness
which i still can't play because it
makes me motion sick but astrobot
uh rescue mission moss so even like a
couple of vr games in there thumper
paper beast
uh funimation uh so you get that anime
and then in april you're gonna get
horizon uh zero dawn which is like
it's really really cool but i kind of i
love the fact that playstation doing it
but just like is do you think this is
indicative that they are
thinking about doing some kind of game
pass model i would say it's one of those
things does playstation even
need something like game pass like
admittedly it seems
like the market of games is kind of
almost
steering towards the subscription model
like it's basically following what tvs
and movies did where they're like oh
netflix is just like dominating anything
that
something like blockbuster can do so
let's all make streaming services
excuse me streaming services like
netflix blockbuster
john's getting emotional i feel you i
miss black i missed it
i miss it so much but it's one of
those things that playstation has
like this unique like
i won't even say opportunity but just
this thing that whenever they have
a big first party game come out like god
of war or
horizon zero dawn or spider-man it just
causes everyone who owns a playstation
to suddenly turn on their playstation
again if they haven't been using it for
the past few weeks or months or
something like that so they don't
necessarily
need someone to regularly check in on
their store they just know it's like oh
when we
launch god of war ragnarok or whatever
it's going to be called
a bunch of people are going to turn on
their ps4s ps5s and
if we can get like at least 30 of them
to be like oh i wonder what's in the
store
they're probably just going to go into
the store and maybe buy something
during that 20 hour experience or what
however long that god of war game
ends up being microsoft doesn't have
that they're not like oh by the way halo
infinite is coming out gears of war is
coming out yeah
so i mean i don't know if i can see
playstation doing that
straight away i can i can definitely see
them doing more offers like for example
if god of war does come out uh
this year i can see them giving wait god
of war's already free
other similar situations like if they if
they have like a next like a ps5 version
of one of their franchises or a ps5 um
uh game coming out i can totally see
them giving away like the game that came
before on ps4 for free i can see them
doing that
um or i just wanted to slip this in
there before we uh before we move on
but disco elysium if you own it on pc
you are gonna get that
ps4 slash five version for free
and you get to hang out with kuno kuno
here
kudo one of the best games
of 2019 possibly all time a game sport
10 out of 10
if you own of all time wow big words
get look i'm i'm coming out with all the
spicy takes spicy takes today
uh but yeah it's like seriously it's
gonna be
i'm very excited to see on playstation
i'm excited to play through that again
and just listen to that music and just
uh generally
wallow in the blaze in the malays of
that game
uh but it is free so i just wanted to
bring that up nintendo is a weird one
within the context of like the free game
conversation
because outside of switch online and
giving away
nes and snares that's right i'm british
i'm not going to say it
how how are you it's nes and snes
is just like he's insane those are not
words they're not they're acronyms
it's fine you say things like do you
do you pronounce your full acronyms for
everything
yeah i'm trying to desperately think of
an example yeah i guess
i guess you guys do american football
guys do you say
american football won by the uh niffle
and the uh
the basketball and the bard nintendo
outside of the free nes and snazz games
on switch online
they're not really known for just like
giving away free stuff
as much yeah not exactly benevolent with
their free gifts
are they um so it's kind of
like we did that video a couple weeks
ago about what we want to see from
switch pro and one of the things we're
talking about was
definitely want to see something on
switch online where they're bringing
things like wii games 3ds
obviously it's you know difficult there
has to be porting work done there has to
be stuff
behind the scenes i'm not just saying
hey put wii games on
on twitch like i'm putting games on the
snazz
nintendo but you know it would be cool
to see nintendo
and sony take more relief from xbox's
book that's so weird give us some free
games nintendo
you can afford it
i mean considering that they won't even
knock like breath of the wild under like
forty
dollars nintendo's nintendo's nintendo's
thing is and how it has always been to
like double down on the value of games
like
by discounting things and giving them
away from free the mentality is like
you know we devalue it for the people
that purchased it and that kind of
business which is
i think a very narrow way of looking at
it but at the very least like
chuck some discounts in them and come on
every now and then like
gizmates rates yeah please base rates
and
you know if you're gonna give us a free
game just do it unequivocally don't be
like
this free game has a countdown timer of
one day on it and if you don't buy it
yeah you're done
if you don't get it you're done and then
we're gonna delete it from your hard
drive even if you do buy it yeah
hey we've been talking about free games
for a long time uh let us know
we brought up some interesting points
about you know like what game pass and
free games does for uh the
people out there like finishing games
are you finding yourself finishing games
less now that you have more access to
free games or more often because you
have more games to finish let us know in
the comments below
um we'll be back again next week uh it's
gonna be a big week because we've
obviously got monster hunter rise on
switch so let us know if you're excited
for that one
uh you can find me on twitter at lucy
james games tam
i'm matt moore hitch i just remember
jake did an oblivion video we're talking
about morrowind earlier you should check
out that oblivion video if that video is
baller
it's great i loved it uh to celebrate
the 15th anniversary
of oblivion uh jordan what about you
find me at jm remain please download
game pass and play i can fell
do it do it do it do it best soundtrack
of last year best soundtrack
easily by country mile damn in a year
that had
hades saying it was better soundtrack
persona
michael hyam doesn't listen to this
first new album came out you know
it's the soundtrack to our lives yeah is
it
i don't know i know so how do you make
[Music]
that
[Music]
you